It's been just over a month since try to
started backing away from Kobe 0 4, the
country's only reported 16 Covid deaths.
That's in a country of one point four
billion people.
Given what we know from other places
after they're reopened, as well as
China's own experience, the low fatality
rate just doesn't stack up.
You have a situation basically where
we're almost flying blind when it comes
to the Covid daughter in China.
We can't trust the cases.
Data is completely not representative.
They have severely narrowed the
definition of what a Covid death is.
China, like a lot of places in the
world, saw anybody who died while they
were Covid positive as a code did.
Now many people who die while Covid
positive from a respiratory condition
are counted as a cause of death.
And that's why you've seen a dramatic
drop in the number of deaths and you
just not see any deaths reported on some
Sunday.
Despite what we know today, a rip
roaring outbreak.
Beijing seems to have been hit hardest.
We're hearing about crematoriums that
have been overwhelmed, hospitals with
bodies piling up
because it's in their interests now that
they've switched to living with Covid.
They want to see a really big bang fast
outbreak that they can then just move on
from official rhetoric from scientists
to the top leaders.
Is that Covid is very mild.
You're very unlikely to die from it.
That is something you can work with.
There's no doubt that Covid 0 the
lockdown is hugely damaging to China's
economy.
That was a key pressure point on why
they needed to shift away from it.
Because Covid is coursing through the
country, people are sick.
People are afraid of being sick.
People aren't out consuming and you are
going to see disruption on what is the
world's factory floor.
But what a lot of economists are betting
is that that first initial wave will
pass over a couple of months and then
people like they have elsewhere in the
world will do things like revenge
spending.
I do think we will say that, but I think
that people are under playing the fact
that Covid doesn't go away.
It's not going away anywhere in the
world.
So that's something China will have to
grapple with.